Merci Monsieur le Président. Madame la Première Ministre,
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ministres, mes chers collègues.
Trois années ont passé,
la douleur de l'assassinat de Samuel Paty est encore présente,
rouverte à vif par celui de Dominique Bernard à Arras, ma ville,
où l'émotion est à son comble.
Une fois de plus, l'école est une cible
pour ceux qui en veulent à nos valeurs, qui en veulent à notre République.
Mais le terroriste a trouvé sur son chemin des héros avec un sang-froid admirable.
Enseignants, agents, policiers, au péril de leur propre vie,
en ont sauvé de nombreuses.
Et les mots sont trop faibles pour les remercier et leur rendre hommage.
Et si le temps est au deuil et au recueillement, il n'occulte pas tout à fait les questions.
Après trois décennies d'attentats
et une trentaine de lois,
l'arsenal juridique et policier existe.
Est-il suffisant ?
L'attentat d'Arras montre malheureusement qu'il y a des failles.
Alors pour autant, une énième loi de circonstance n'a guère d'intérêt.
J'en appelle donc à la sagesse du Sénat pour trouver
dans la future loi immigration les réponses justes et fermes.
Mais il faut miser aussi et surtout
sur une véritable politique éducative et parentale,
impérative pour réarmer moralement la jeunesse.
L'école doit demeurer un sanctuaire,
à l'abri de la violence de certains foyers et des idéologies mortifères,
un lieu où on apprend et où on s'émancipe.
Alors monsieur le ministre de l'Éducation nationale,
vous avez rencontré des enseignants à Arras, bouleversés par le drame.
Ils attendent vos réponses à leurs questions, et je vous en pose deux.
Qu'allez-vous faire pour assurer la protection des établissements scolaires ?
Les grilles et les circulaires ne suffiront pas.
Et qu'allez-vous faire aussi pour que le travail éducatif et civique
mené par Samuel Paty et Dominique Bernard,
et que même tous les enseignants de notre pays,
ne soient pas vains ?
Merci.